اجواء دائما حميميه بعد انتهاء المباراه
يقوم المشجعون بالذهاب الى هذه المنطقه
منطقه شارب او سوق واقف ولكن اليوم هو
اليوم الثاني من تصفيات الربع النهائي
ستكون المنافسه اوروبيه بامتياز على ملعب
الثمامه هنا في قطر الساعه 8:00 ليلا
بتوقيت الدوحه والرياض تنطلق مباراه فرنسا
وبولندا للتاهل الى الربع النهائي في
بطوله كاس العالم فيفا قطر
لمباراه فرنسا وبولندا
هو صعب وعلينا الانتباه والتاكد باننا
جاهزون للفوز بهذه المباراه عندنا هون
كثير من الشباب الفرنسي الذي وصل يوم امس
الى هنا همم
فرنسا المنتخب
ههه
اوكي نعم هو قال قال وبحماس كما شاهدنا
انه مستعدون للفوز بهذه المباراه التي
ستقام بين فرنسا وبولندا الساعه 8:00 مساء
يقومون بمشاهده المباراه وبعد ذلك
دبي وسيتابعوا المباراه من هناك هذه
الاجواء يعني كثير من الفرنسيه الذين
قدموا قدموا الى قطر الى الدوحه من مناطق
مختلفه من فرنسا ليس فقط من الدول
المجاوره الكثير من الفرنسيه
من المشجعين كذلك صباح كل يوم مباراه
ويعودون الى بلادهم او مكان سكناهم على
الاقل همم في مساء اليوم او اليوم الذي
يتبع اذا كان هناك نصر طبعا
المفضل لكن هي مباراه قليله التي جمعت
ربما فرنسا وبولندا ااه هي مباراه واحده
جمعتهم في كاس العالم كان الفوز من نصيب
فرنسا مباراه تقريبا في الثمانينات
اليوم هل يعتقد الفرنسيون بان المواجهه
ستكون اصعب مما يتوقعون ام ان مبابي
ورفاقه
قادرون على تجاوز منافس صعب كابلندا
مره اخرى مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي خالد على
اهميه مباراه بولندا اليوم اتقال يجب ان
تكون في افضل او نقول في افضل حالاتنا حتى
لا تحدث المفاجات مثل المباراه امام تونس
التي كان فيها لاعبون تونس متحمسون مع
المسانده الجماهيريه او التشجيع الكبير
الذي شاهدناه في الملعب التي كانت مصدر
حماسيهم وعن مباراه اليوم بين فرنسا
وبولندا اكد
مدير المنتخب او رئيس
مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي ان المنتخب البولندي
خصم صعب ولاعبوه يمتلكون خبره كبيره يعني
ويتميز باسلوبه الدفاعي عناصر ممتازه في
الخط الهجومي